she went to Australia and I want to ask
you this a fan brought a patriot shirt
yeah and I I'm just gonna full
disclosure I love you I
I'm a patriot I was born in Boston just
cuz I was born in Boston you got a me
loyal to the team anywho a Patriots fan
had the nerve to walk up to you in
Australia and hand you a shirt to sign
you Marshawn Lynch and you signed what
is this here yes that's his shirt that
you sign all right so I would say there
so I'm crossed out the page you've
crossed out Patriots yeah she hogs
beasts mo you [ __ ] you been let go that
was at the end you see it's more writing
under there there's more writing under
that yeah so to turn huge that's the
time that we use back when I'm from
Oakland I stay on the you block you
friend me though so when we said come
through to you you need right so it was
like a joke right he got it but
everybody else didn't get it cuz it just
you see the Seahawks be smoke you eat
right right yeah you weren't actually
being confrontational you're actually
being making a joke and the guy got it
and then he got it but you know I see
you you only see part of the picture but
let me ask you a question you told me
once cuz we hang out a lot
you told me once that I had street cred
in the Tina Oakland yeah you told me I
had street cred in Oakland true is that
true if I'm not with you and Oakland I'd
have street cred yeah and you wouldn't
have to say nothing
besides it's like there you go nothing
looks like you [ __ ]
no not
although you'll [ __ ] no no no II got a
flowing let it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you